you're trying to catch just the teeny
bit of sunlight that's going through the
planets you want to see the light that's
come from the star through the
atmosphere bounced off the planet come
back out through the atmosphere and
thereby acquired some fingerprints there
will be some wavelengths at which there
is no sunlight or starlight because it's
been absorbed by these chemical
constituents of the atmosphere very hard
this is not going to happen tomorrow so
if there's a gap at oxygen then you know
that there was some oxygen in that
atmosphere yes yeah but you wouldn't
necessarily know whether it was produced
by al'lat by biology or by breaking
apart water molecule into hydrogen and
oxygen so there there are false
positives there's this whole question of
what really constitutes a bio signature
and it's going to be I think full of
caveats we're going to have to tease it
out we're gonna have to know something
more about the star and the planet and
even their history if we can to decide
whether this oxygen has been produced by
biology or by some abiotic process and
this is bio signature work and then my
world is not looking for the microbes
it's looking for the mathematicians so
we're looking for love that one who just
can you just play it down for a second
the microbe looking for the microbes is
the bio signatures looking for the
mathematicians is looking for the techno
signatures that's so funny okay so tell
us why you say this well we're looking
for something that mother nature can't
do that requires an engineer to produce
and and they can be there are many
different possibilities historically
we've been looking for radio signals
we've been looking for optical flashes
but indeed you can think about general
astroengineering they might be modifying
their planet and this project reminder
seeks to remind us that we're all just a
bunch of humans and we're in
together now now it's so tough when
civilization evolves with borders it
becomes so difficult to imagine what
it's like without borders it's well
we've been just what borders since you
know we were dirt so it's just part of
the evolutionary process and it's
something that we all have to
collectively agree on we got to tear
down these walls and borders and go
forward otherwise we'll just become
another lost civilization in which this
planet is littered with I think borders
are fine and they you're right they're
totally natural and it you could kind of
I just think we need to move up one more
level in terms of how we're thinking
about our fellow man so like if you look
at the United States right we have like
we have the states and those are those
are distinctly separate you know they
have their own governments and their own
laws but well it's like what's more
important is that we're like we're
American and like the countries sorry
the country as a whole acts together and
I don't think we really have that as the
globe as like the human species so I'd
like to push us more towards okay first
we are human oh and then like below that
unless unless importance are these
things we've created called Nations yeah
but they're so important yeah right
around summer of 2007 just before the
beginning of the summer there was a
series of shootings in the neighborhood
and that really galvanized the community
to say what are we going to do if this
is happening and we're not at summer yet
so let's really be intentional about
what we're doing for our young people
and that forced the service providers to
come together and we started a series of
things like mid-tour series where we
started then taking young people from
the Western Addition to visit tech
companies to meet with people who were
in the industry to think about that as a
career opportunity to be able to
envision themselves in that space you
see you can be it exactly right and then
we also started to say like let's do
some training and workshops that do
hands-on so that they're learning this
right so that by the time they
from high school they can consider
pathways and have a more concrete of the
idea of it I'm so that was one another
was family engagement around literacy so
we started I started this having come
from being a teacher books and literacy
and were really important to me so we
started buying books for all the service
providers that were offering summer
programs and then that has since grown
to actually doing curriculum because we
had a lot of people say look we're a rec
center kids come here they play ball you
what do you want us to do with these
books so then we get the books and say
this is what parents can do this is what
service providers can do this is what
young people can do and started getting
books like there's a book called a to
twist the scientist which had an
african-american girl as the the lead in
the book and talks about like her
experimentation and all the stuff she
does as a scientist there's another one
called eggy Peck the architect which is
about a kid who loves to build with like
diapers and pancakes and again just this
idea of stem so infusing that and saying
playing with LEGOs is stemmed right just
being getting to have those
conversations yeah and then another one
is just this overall internship program
so those were kind of critical like how
do we build up the service providers
that are working in this community how
do we give them the resources to do this
work and then how do we build up the
young people so that was kind of at the
heart of it and then it was simple
things that we take for granted where we
raised money to take every kid in the
neighborhood to Great America or to
Santa Cruz so it literally ten bus loads
of kids at one time 700 kids from the
neighborhood world going to those places
so we were building community we were
building the village because Boys and
Girls Club knew kids from the YMCA the
YMCA knew the public housing kids
everybody on a bus together spending the
day in community which is now grown to
every Wednesday during the summer all
700 of those kids from around the
neighborhood come together and do some
activity throughout the city so from
that I was asked to run a community
center and was doing the community
center work and then started serving on
the
Rights Commission and then from there
when the director of Human Rights
Commission left um was asked to go into
that space while the city looked for a
new director and then ultimately was
asked to stay in that position a term I
had heard I heard recently which was
kind of new for me was dead fishing so
it's a tactic that some people often
women but I'm sure men use it also is if
they're in a sexual situation that they
are uncomfortable with or don't want to
continue they'll often like kind of go
limp and stop interacting that can often
be like a trauma response that people
have histories of abuse or assault or it
can just be like this is awkward and I
don't want it to happen but I also like
don't want to make the person mad or
upset them so some some tips that I that
we included in the in the in the sort of
intro welcome to a femoral here's the
bullet points was that some signals to
look out for that someone might be
uncomfortable as if they stopped
reciprocating trusts or sorry if they
stopped reciprocating touch or if
they're avoiding eye contact or if
they're failing to respond to like a
verbal asked for is this okay does this
feel good do you want me to keep doing
this so if they're not responding if
they're not responsive that's often a
sign of discomfort so and the the advice
at that point is just like stop what
you're doing and wait until you have
clarity different hospitals have
different volumes of pure heart surgical
procedures that they perform we do about
a thousand heart surgery procedures a
year and so there you can do the math I
mean that's three a day well at least
more than more than that so
you know it's about up you know four
four cases to five cases a day and
you're doing one of those well all the
surgeons have a have a caseload on on
average people are operating about four
four times a week for cases or cases a
we yeah they some are some sums
sometimes more sometimes less and the
human hearts usually plagued by heart
disease or some sort of an issue that
needs attention we instituted Universal
High School in 1911 so an in large part
because of a response to what was
happening so the Industrial Revolution
was really really rough and this time is
gonna be much much worse according to
being it's going to require labor
absorption at between three and four
times the rate of the Industrial
Revolution
what is Labor absorption well what that
means is that you have workers we're
losing their jobs we managed to find new
jobs and so the Industrial Revolution
again massive conflicts and strife and
according to being this time you're
going to need to somehow have
reintegration of labor at a much much
higher pace and if you look at the
numbers right now they're really
discouraging because the efficacy rates
of government-sponsored retraining are
between zero and thirty seven percent
really bad I mean thirty-seven is being
very very generous honestly because
that's just one study said thirty-seven
percent of people trained this industry
went into that industry and so some of
that would have happened without the
retraining presumably so we're terrible
at retraining and right now the rates of
Americans moving from one state to
another for any reason also at a
multi-decade low so you have a labor
market that's not dynamic at all and
then you're saying hey it's time to to
have a transition happen at four times
the rate of the Industrial Revolution
I mean the odds of that happening
magically painlessly seamlessly zero
essentially and and our government is
again the sleep of the switch where
instead of putting to work massive
incentives or
really empowering people to be able to
adapt we're just hoping the market
figures it out which it will not how
does one in a position of being
underserved or underrepresented how do
they maximize their potential through
their individual abilities well this is
a good question and this is actually
like the issue too because um
generational poverty comes with
generational trauma and generational
trauma comes with low self-esteem
emotional dysregulation and lack of
ability to see into the future
helplessness and hopelessness coping
mechanisms that are dysfunctional before
mine right so in order for us to tell in
it for an order for an individual
experiencing generational poverty to
want to be able to get out of it and
help themselves first we have to
actually help them understand what
happened to them and see that it's
actually not your individual fault or
not the fall of your family or community
this is something systemic
and this is something that has been
going on right that's a form of
empowerment because then it opened up
their eyes like oh wow okay I see now
this is just like a machine that's doing
this not my individual issues not my own
family's individual issue on my race or
my gender this individual issue right
and then you have to basically be able
to motivate that individual you have to
expose them to new opportunities new
people new spaces helping them develop
new neural pathways new ways of thinking
being in doing or else you can throw all
kinds opportunities at them and
nothing's gonna stick and I have
first-hand experience with this because
I am I do work with like homeless youth
disconnected families disconnected youth
and there's a lot of self-defeat because
of the generational trauma and they have
seen nothing but their family members
dying going to jail being on drugs
homeless whatever sold they already it's
a basically and they start to have
something where it's a manifest destiny
they they're like
gonna be my path so why do any of this
anyway it's right and then they start to
basically facilitate their own
destruction and their own demise so
that's why when folks are like well you
know they have all these nonprofits they
have welfare did it how come they just
can't make themselves better it's
because we're not even looking at we're
talking people who've been in the same
situation their cameras been in the same
cycle for hundreds of years right the
machine machine it's a system that is
designed to keep that going right you
just can't come to one day be like oh
you can do a B C and B they're gonna be
like you're trying to scam me because
there's also that level of distress -
you know like already trying to scam me
I don't believe you what do you want to
get out of me
that's why the relationship building a
community building is so important right
in order to help those individuals see
what they can be a mentorship is
important and then being able to see
people who look just like them in these
positions like even me the things that
I'm doing I don't consider myself like
I'll be on say a blockchain or like some
famous person but I know that there are
people now who are looking up to me you
know in order to make things happen I'm
looking up to me as like a mentor
looking up to me as a role model so of
course oh yeah yeah I conduct myself a
certain way and at the same time - I
have those people in my world you know
who help me see the best of myself you
know so I think that's it and that's why
I would blotching for social justice
when we're talking about how we do the
economic health fairs we have to talk
about social justice we have to talk
about inequities - so people understand
that there's a system put in place for
you to not get opportunities it's not
you not doing enough it's not you being
lazy
there's a stack of hurdles and barriers
set up for you to be able to not get
well there's all kinds of different
types of encryption the bigger the key
is the harder it is to break but
encryption isn't how many how many
characters yeah or things I'd say that
children how many how many you know so
if you're doing a es 256 encryption okay
which is a standard right and and I had
somebody say I lost my key and I need to
get it back how long will it take was
probably ten times ten to the 52nd power
if you were to go to all the iterations
to try to find that key now you might
get lucky and find in the first five
years of your life but ten times ten to
the fifty second is a whole lot of time
and
you know a single computers not going to
do it so the bigger that number 256 128
is after it the harder it is to do that
are we doing like more than 256 right
now right I don't think I've seen
anything beyond that that that can
reasonably be done and is that taking
like your file let's say it's a just
classic PDF file you don't want anyone
to see it right so then you're taking
the ones and zeros and you're you're
changing the numbers so just just think
of it as oh gosh I'm trying to think
there's some really good movies out
there but the very first Tom Hanks one
angels and demons you I think you know
we're talking about right and they talk
about encryption if you're changing it
in such a way that only you know how to
undo it
that's encryption so you're not doing a
simple substitution but you're just
changing in such a way that you're the
only one who knows how to put it back -
right so you can read it and you have to
have the key to do that without this key
you can't put it back - right so that's
that's encryption in its simplest form
and you probably don't want to write
that on like some paper sort of laying
around yeah that's that's usually not
agreeing stories crypto key yeah well
where do you then like what is a good
place Oh key storage places that you can
sort I don't they see it too though um
you know there's some trust factors that
have to go into some of these things you
do have there does come a time like you
have to trust something cuz I does IBM
tells clients that they'll take care of
them if we're doing if we're running
their systems for them a lot of times we
will have the key or that data and
sometimes what's how the client will
feel more console they kept the key mmm
it just depends to be honest with you so
there's that um then there's obvious
casein is this you make it look like
something else you try to hide it you
just try to hide it you know so social
security patterns because when people
try to look like for social security you
know you're you're technically looking
for the pattern you know three numbers -
two numbers - four numbers so you know
take it out jumble it around you don't
make it look so obvious that that's what
it is
and
you know security to your office station
as we say it's not the rightest thing to
do but some people still believe it
works it can work it can work and in
some cases Oh simple things for for
testing the fences if there's a week
slow we'll get we'll get there we'll get
there but yeah okay and then and then
but I think everybody has agreed that
the the most common is what we call
depth and defense so think of a castle
so you've got the castle this is your
enterprise and you've built these
concentric moats around them of
different times some of them might have
oil and fire and some of them might be
water and some of these might be
crocodiles or snakes or whatever okay
and they're just concentric circles and
for a bad person to break in they have
to cross all those concentric circles
the more circles you have their heart of
the circles are that's called depth and
defense so that's the easiest way to
explain it I could go into you know host
some truce into text and stuff like that
and then people's eyes glaze over and
they get lost so it's easier to explain
it with the castle mode that's really
resigned kind of mentality kind of thing
so you get a notification when they
start attacking the first moat you
should get a notification if you've done
it properly should get a notification
when they're trying to cross the first
month even the moats way way out to be
not people watching right you got two
watches out there watching it kind of
thing so you with your security
operation center and so there's those
kinds of Defense's that we talked about
you know we like to have encryption
because it's if for some reason some it
does get all the way through you're just
making it harder for them to get the
data and get at the data so we like to
encrypt it yep you know and we can't
depend any more on all these depth and
defense decryptions now as we move to
the cloud either hmm because you know
that relies on somebody because some
people sometimes people have forgotten
all this stuff exists so when they move
to the cloud they forget that they have
to re-enable all that stuff because they
haven't been doing it there's an
enterprise people on high you know some
some group over here has been doing it
for them and they forget that it existed
and so in order to the cloud sometimes
they forget they need to do all these
things still again to protect it so you
know
you try to make it harder for them to do
that kind of stuff and then you try to
remind folks your application must
defend itself also so and that's an old
concept that's becoming new again
actually so when I went to university
that was one of the things they taught
you you defend yourself you do not
depend on anything else so that would be
like you'd be a very rich person and not
being you know shown to have any
hand-to-hand combat moves or anything
like that you know I just look cute and
walk around and it's some of the taxing
a blunt Tulsa definitely so so now you
want to teach this thing to defend
itself you want to teach it some
hand-to-hand combat you want to teach it
to reject things that look strange and
silly and things like that so the
application was not defend itself - so
you want to make sure they can't get
through through concentric moats if they
do get through the concentric moats you
want to make sure they can't get at the
data because you're moving it around
it's encrypted so somebody can snoop
around they can't see it they're gonna
what this was like garbage let me look
at the drive that looks like garbage now
let me see if I mean in the application
of the application spend in the office
if you do all that that's really good
security - yeah privacy there right
that's sounds like world-class security
it is world-class security if you do all
those things